just a second here I guess we're gonna
get started now that was quick good
morning everybody welcome to the by
Nicki Rare Book and Manuscript library I
might tell her I'm the director of the
wyndham Campbell literature prizes on
behalf of the by Nicki library & Young
University welcome to the 2015 prize
winners announcement I'll just say a few
words about the prizes before I hand it
over to president Sall of a who will
make the announcement the wyndham
campbell prizes call attention to
literary achievement and provide writers
with the opportunity to focus on their
work independent of financial concerns
awards are made to english language
writers at all stages of their careers
from anywhere in the world writers can
be nominated for outstanding promise or
for a body of work today's recipients
did not know they had been nominated
nominations were solicited
confidentially from literary and theater
professionals from across the globe each
prize winners nomination passed through
a selection process that included the
nomination letter a jury that selected
the finalists and a selection committee
that made the final determinations all
nominators jurors and selection
committee members agreed to do their
work anonymously I'd like to thank all
of them for the fine work they've done
in nominating and selecting this year's
prize winners I'd also like to thank the
wyndham kit Campbell prize steering
committee the office of the president
and the director and staff of the by
Nikki Rare Book and Manuscript library
for their support I will return to
answer questions that you might have
after the announcement there are some
microphones set up over there so if you
are thinking you want to ask a question
do you want to position yourself and on
that side of the room and without
further ado I'd like to introduce yells
president Peter salafi who will announce
the prize winners
thank you Michael good morning everyone
this is a one of my favorite days of the
year and I am really pleased to be able
to announce the prize winners we are
honored to be the home of the wyndham
Campbell prizes and literary festival
and we're especially grateful to the
late donald windham and sandy campbell
for creating this legacy this year there
were 61 nominees from 12 countries from
this group nine have been selected to
receive the prize which comes with a
citation diploma and a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to support their
writing so I will now announce the names
of the 2015 prize winners and i will
read their citations the wyndham
campbell prizes for nonfiction are
awarded to from the united kingdom
Edmund ivalo edmund of all sure
narrative instinct and lyrical
imagination inform a deeply felt
examination of the hold that objects
have on our personal and collective
memory also from the United Kingdom
Geoff Dyer omnivorous Lee curious and
psychologically probing Jeff dyers
writings reinvent again and again the
possibilities of nonfiction discovering
as many new subjects as he does ways of
writing about them from the United
States John Jeremiah Sullivan John
Jeremiah Sullivan's wide-ranging Zubrin
essays engaged a full spectrum of
American life with passion precision and
wit the wyndham Campbell prizes for
drama are awarded to from the United
States Jackie Sibley's drury Jackie
Drury deftly blends historical inquiry
and meta theatrical experiment to
challenge assumptions about race
performance
and individual responsibility from the
United Kingdom Helen Edmondson Helen
Edmonton's ambitious plays to still
historical complexities through
character whose passions and ethical
dilemmas mirror and illuminate a larger
political landscape also from the United
Kingdom Debbie Tucker green pushing
speech and silence to the limit Debbie
Tucker greens plays expose the brutal
choices of individuals bound by the
imperatives of family society and love
the wyndham Campbell prizes for fiction
are awarded to from Nigeria and the
United States teju cole teja coles
peripatetic nerrit narrators like his
prose revel in the possibilities and
limitations of global urbanity
navigating the fine line between choice
and circumstance perception and memory
also from nigeria halen ha bila halen
hey Beulah is that rare combination of
storyteller stylist who challenges
expectations while deepening our empathy
for ordinary people confronting
extraordinary times from South Africa
Yvonne vladislav each Yvonne vitae
slavich's fiction explores the
uncomfortable aftermath of apartheid
through inventive meditations on the
complex intersection of history politics
and art so the prizes will be conferred
at a ceremony and literary festival here
at yell that begins September 28th 2015
this fall all nine Prize winners will
come to yell to participate we thank
these winners for the ways in which
their work has enriched to all of us and
we congratulate them
on this incredible achievement I look
forward to meeting all of them in
September and hopefully seeing all of
you at the festival as well so thank you
all for joining us today and let me
bring back Michael to answer any
questions that you might have thank you
for being here on this special occasion
Michael thank you Peter so if you have
questions if you could please address
them to the microphone there so that
they get picked up on the livestream
we're being watched all over the world
live right now and and so part of this
is for them yes in the back hi my
question is about the festival I wonder
if you can say anything about what plans
are our shape taking shape for September
the wyndham Campbell prize festival has
been an extraordinary addition to our
rich literary events programs here at
Yale and I'm interested in knowing
what's coming up thank you we have yet
to start planning I think everybody is
still recovering from the shock of the
phone call they received last week but
over the next couple of weeks I will be
in touch with all of the prizewinners to
talk to them and get to know them a
little bit and figure out ways that we
can best show them and show their work
to the audience of the festival and so
hopefully we'll be continuing the
traditions that we've we've begun in the
last couple of years doing events around
campus using the drama school and and
and trying to spread the prizewinners
far and wide both you know because of
the categories that they're writing in
but also because of the different ideas
that they're interested in and I think
one of the unique things about the
festival every year is that we always
find people who have interesting ideas
that are coming into the festival and
and Yale is a wonderful place because no
matter what I do you have there's
somebody here who's thinking about it so
thank you any particular stories of that
struck you from the recipients of the
phone calls well you know this year we I
did it a little bit differently in the
past few years I've made all the phone
calls myself the day after we made the
prize selections and this year I started
sending them emails while we still had a
few hours
left we had already made the selections
and we were writing the citations the
the the selection committee writes all
the prize citations as a group at the
end of the day and it's actually a very
arduous process because everybody's
tired from the conversation of the
morning and so in mid-afternoon I just
started sending them emails asking for
their phone numbers would they call me
or send me their phone number and people
started calling me immediately and and
so I started while they were writing the
citations I was getting phone calls
about every 30 minutes from a shocked
prize winner and i would put them on
speakerphone and tell them they had just
one hundred fifty thousand dollars and i
think my favorite one this year i think
we're the prizes are becoming a bit more
well-known now and so i don't think
anybody thought that it was a Nigerian
phishing scam this year which they did
quite a few of them did last year I
think my favorite response this year one
of the prizewinners said took a moment
then she said you know in front of the
whole selection committee she said you
know if this is a practical joke this is
the meanest practical joke anyone has
ever played on me but you know as ever I
mean people i think were no as far as I
could tell nobody had any idea that they
had been nominated they were all very
surprised and very appreciative and and
and really touched by the fact that that
first of all they were on the radar and
second of all that their prize
nomination went through this very long
rigorous process and ended up selecting
them all right fire away can you speak
to the international character of the
prizes is there an effort to scan all
over the english-language world to find
people there is there is I mean we we
have a limited number of nominations
that are available each year only about
20 to 25 in each category so within that
I seek to cast as wide a net as possible
while also maintaining the high
standards of the nominees that we've
come to expect every year so not every
country in the english-speaking world
gets represented every single year but
when they do get represented we try to
make sure that
there's a certain amount of saturation
so that when judges are looking at their
work they're seeing other writers from
those parts of the world and comparing
them to each other but also comparing
them to writers from everywhere else and
and so we do I travel to other countries
I spent two weeks in Australia last
summer meeting a lot of the literary
folks from down there so hopefully
they'll have some solid representation
in the coming years and and I continue
to do that in two different in different
parts of the world anybody else okay
well thank you very much for coming and
congratulations to all of our prize
winners we look forward to meeting all
of you in September see you next year
you